this is the AMC on East Illinois Street
in Chicago the plink 17 movies you
actually have 21 options because there's
so many formats
should you see Toy Story 4 in 3d digital
you know what's don't why does it cost
18 bucks could you undo you pick if
you've bought a movie ticket in the last
decade you've seen this a bunch of
different options each with dramatically
different prices the same movie is being
screened but there are a lot of ways it
can be projected in order to figure out
why there are so many formats we need to
find out what these actually need it's
more complicated than the five names you
see listed let's start with the basics
standard sometimes just referred to as
digital this is your average movie
theater experience found anywhere from
regal to a small independent theater
then there's 3d the one with the glasses
usually branded as RealD 3d these
projectors use polarized light to create
the illusion of depth which supposedly
makes the film more immersive but a lot
of people just find it disorienting 3d
movies aren't as popular as they once
were
in fact in 2018 the MPAA reported a 20%
year-over-year decrease in the global 3d
box office all right
let's ditch those 3d glasses and check
out the newest format to hit theaters
Dolby dolby digital cinemas made by
Dolby can be found at AMC theaters it
uses dual 4k laser projectors that's
four times more resolution than a
standard theater projector these
projectors produce super crisp images
with deep blacks and bright highlights
at 500 times the contrast ratio and
twice the brightness of a standard
projector Dobie is the best HDR you can
get with ear high dynamic range means
really bright highlights and really dark
blacks Dolby cinema images appear less
muddy or a great compared to
traditional projectors overall it's
supposed to create a more realistic
image and it reminds you over and over
with this video yeah we get it but the
biggest difference with Toby is their
sound system they call it Dolby Atmos
all movie theaters use surround sound
that means using more speakers so the
viewer can hear sounds from the
direction they're supposed to be coming
from on screen like behind you or to
your right but Dolby Atmos is like super
surround sound it uses many more
speakers to completely surround the
viewer
there are even speakers on the ceiling
and transducers which produce bass under
the seats there's also a version of
Dolby that offers 3d movies thanks to
the higher-quality projectors the image
actually appears brighter than with
traditional review and then there's IMAX
you've probably heard of violence
because it's actually been around since
the seventies but this can get a little
confusing because unlike Dolby not every
IMAX theater is the same unique to IMAX
is its huge screen which is bigger than
any other format up to 40% larger and it
uses an aspect ratio that's taller than
other theaters with some movies this
means you're seeing more of the image
instead of black bars on the top and
bottom of the frame the newest IMAX
theaters use dual 4k laser projectors
and have an upgraded sound system but if
you buy an IMAX ticket you might not be
getting your money's worth
depending on your theater you may be
getting what some refer to as lime acts
these lime acts
IMAX experience theaters have a smaller
screen and lower resolution projectors
it's not clear just from buying your
ticket if your theater is IMAX with
laser or lime acts but you can check
this website to find out like there will
be some theaters also offer IMAX 3d but
if you're walking out of your IMAX movie
wondering why the screen felt smaller
than last time
might spot one more logo our px is
Riegel's own large format experience
offering bigger screens newer projectors
and an updated sound system that list
probably sounds familiar by now
basically architects will look and sound
better than a standard movie theater but
it's not as premium as Dolby or IMAX
with laser oh yeah there's also for DX
but uh that's its own thing this is a
lot of information but that's actually
just digital some films offer special
screenings where you can view actual
film being projected dunkirk and the
hateful eight offered seventy millimeter
screenings seventy millimeter is huge
more than six times bigger than standard
35 millimeter film there's also 70
millimeter high max which is how IMAX
first started some moviegoers enjoy film
projections because it creates a more
organic and less sterile image compared
to vision besides 70 millimeters some
theaters still offer 35 millimeter film
projections but these are usually for
special events not new releases so yeah
there's a lot more to these screenings
than just their names here are a few
takeaways from all of those specs bigger
screens newer projectors and larger
sound system usually make a better
viewing experience
but if IMAX and doe B are both bigger
and higher quality which is better well
it depends if you want the biggest
screen size you can get you want IMAX
with some screens over 80 feet wide IMAX
is way bigger than Dolby just make sure
it's IMAX with laser but if you're an
audiophile who has to get the best sound
possible go with Dolby Dolby Atmos is
noticeably more immersive than
traditional surround sound Doby theaters
are also usually newer so chances are it
will be better maintained but both Dolby
and IMAX have better quality control
over this
found an image than a standard theater
dobby does offer a crisper brighter
image with deeper blacks than IMAX for
both IMAX with laser and Dolby look
great
the average moviegoer probably wouldn't
notice a difference without seeing these
images side by side but IMAX theaters
also have a taller screen so if you're
watching a movie like Avengers and game
that was specifically shot for IMAX
you'll see more of the image instead of
having black bars on the top and bottom
but projection isn't everything if
you're going to watch a 3-hour Avengers
movie you want to be comfortable certain
theaters offer reclining seats food
trays or parent seats
these are deal-breaker for some people
the specifics will vary theater to
theater but if you usually check online
before buying your ticket obviously all
of these features won't come cheap
if you want to see a newer higher
quality format your ticket is going to
cost more now if all you wanted was to
see a movie on a hot summer day
this might seem silly to you but some
people are passionate about how they
watch a movie and can blame them movie
tickets have hit an average price of
over nine dollars nationwide and in big
cities it's even more expensive if
you're paying a bunch of money you want
the best experience possible all of
these formats give movie goers more
choice if you just want to see a comedy
with some friends standard digital is
probably fine but you're seeing the big
blockbuster you've been waiting a year
for might be worth the extra money to
see it in the biggest format available
different genres lend themselves to
different formats and these formats give
directors and cinematographers more
choices to Christopher Nolan shot parts
of Dunkirk with an IMAX camera which
made those exterior shots feel large and
epic while the interior shots felt tight
and confined the taller IMAX effect
ratio was used to add more impact to the
story and sound designers are able to be
more detailed and creative on using a
system like Dolby Atmos all these
formats give filmmakers the opportunity
to tell their story the way they want
of course it helps theaters to formats
like Dolby and IMAX are a reason to go
to the theater instead of watching at
home but you want crispy Dolby or grainy
35-millimeter you've got a lot of
options and that's a good thing
imagine if 3d was the only way you could
see a movie